2020 the year of the bat  it's been trying to stop comedy but it  can't stop chrissy chaos  coronavirus showed up in my body and saw  there were too many viruses already so  it had to pick a different body than in  fact  october 23rd 8 pm go to wall street  theater dot live for tickets  i'm doing a live streaming stand up  comedy show it's like pay-per-view for  stand-up  it's going to be wild you can get it  wherever you live in the world for 24  hours  buy the tickets invite your whole family  over you just got to buy it on one tv  if you want to go see a comedy show  right now you probably die if covered  and spend hundreds of dollars  this is 25 for one ticket wall street  theater dot live it's what jesus wants  you to do if you don't do your communist  pig  [Music]  if you don't support this special then  you support the virus october 23rd  8pm wall street theater dot live